there's something that looks like
there's new cobwebs in here huh no don't
trust that probably fine probably
definitely fine
oh all right so welcome to pistol whip
now pistol whip is like beat saber in
that it's got music training probably
whoo okay shoot enemy dodge bullets okay
so like superhot meets beat saber that
comparison has probably been all aimed
down to reload just like an arcade days
baby losing armor what is that yeah okay
shoot armor to repair does that mean do
I gotta actually step oh look all right
boom boom Oh innocent bystanders oh cool
coming for you pull okay I get it
oh wow do I get to guys Wow Oh tiny
itty-bitty gun
[Music]
let's go I like this one
customized ooh pink aren't done
customized enough let's do black magic
cuz it's the first one in front of me
I'm ready let's do this
I'm gonna show you with my bang bang
pulling free balloon boy am I supposed
to do this to their beat
[Music]
not my music am I supposed to do it do a
beat oh there we go yeah that's right
you're supposed to do it too a beat my
microphone it got hit oh god here we go
again
get me some bullets in your head okay
everyone's dead now except humans that
big cow here we go in the club my name
is markiplier
rub-a-dub oh that ain't good this is
awesome
I got a baby this is like this might be
the coolest thing I've seen Oh
kill them kill them got him that wasn't
off beat you [ __ ] huh there's another
bullet in your head oh [ __ ] no good
right there huh here's a gun and a
bullet I'm not white but I sure act like
it huh there's another bullet there Oh
almost got me with that one who you're
sneaking up on me what not today I got
that way huh here's the little bar for
you I'm out of ready I wish I had
another gun here
I think two guns would be super fun
maybe there's something in the setting
for that everything I'm saying is
slightly to the beat ow
god damn it that was a little unfair you
were too close to dodge right there I
hope I don't die too soon
where's my armor I'm in such blooms
[Music]
oh that holes got me too bad on June 3
ah screw it I don't know if I can
actually do this Oh God blue God
egads hey none of that that's awesome
that is so fun that is so fun that is so
much fun
there's something about that that's just
ridiculously fun um
gun options no no game settings oh I
can't do double gun BAM beep boop boop
beep boop boop boom oh sorry Mike I keep
doing that sorry All Right see you
select might be hard to kill people with
the slower beats okay let's do you know
what let's go for it give me normal I
don't easy come on give me something
good oh what's that in the back of your
dome news dude miss me oh there's my
microphone right in my eyes that kind of
hurt Wow hurt me real bad they're like
you know
huh
okay I got your number now
not today baby you trying to end me I'll
leave you first I'm gonna kill you
enough with the rhymes enough more about
that yeah wow what a pistol with gift
you've given me the chance that because
I'm awesome
due to some violent content parental
discretion is advised
[Music]
two guns right now
hey this feels so good
we got that beat on me
[Music]
missed them out hey why does it hurt me
if I run in bodily to them I feel like
I'm running in bodily to a minute
interviews but yeah I really like that
that's so that's so cool
it's just really cool it's it's just
such an elegant way of doing it it feels
right I like it okay whoo that's a
workout too but this is why two guns
would be great what did that
[Music]
oh not they get u-bahn in a bad way
you get holes in your head oh god here
comes my desk oh wait yours ones -
ascaris I can't ran BAM you go get over
there I'm going to shoot you in the head
you're gonna go straight to bed
oh good oh thank you buddy
boo you dirty my oh I know I look really
lame but I feel so cool out my brain hey
wait a minute
I know I just said I feel I I feel cool
I don't feel cool anymore try again wish
I had two guns
Oh
get off my back pop off my sack go take
a nap here comes the rats
oh there you go oh don't you know
here comes by snow Oh God don't blow it
in there we go it's in the head
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so awesome I can't even fathom
it
Oh fear not and the last last - what how
my brain here comes your death don't
take the breath Oh goddamn s what I am
left out from the pain I will have
gained give me the points oh there we go
Oh God
whoo that's not on feet Oh God here we
go there's there there there there there
there there there I am out of breath
I've got nothing left
this better be the end or my ass all bad
oh god this is like the coolest game
I've ever played this might be very
easily one of the coolest VR games to
play right now this is so much I cannot
express how fun this is
it's beaut to stop I fine let's do this
one hand it is baby one hand coming at
you oh let's do this
[Music]
or no one else but no no mistake was
made when you side face with me mariachi
okay interesting
bang all this this is the coolest thing
god it's so cool
I can't even appreciate the environment
[Music]
whoa you distracted me not cool bro
ow okay I don't like that oh can I go
all the way back to the be a long song
woo you thought you'd give me that but
you could not oh we're going through
again I feel like I've seen this before
it's like I've been here before like I
bet on this floor I've already opened
this door
we're in the dick all right it's gonna
be the same thing again today
oh come on no I thought I got whoa oh
did you think you're gonna get me no not
today
oh not in anyway oh it's calm now no I'm
not gonna let my guard go down you're
not gonna catch me unawares I've got
your number this time and I'm gonna show
you the business end of this musical
pistol it's the breakdown force pulling
Anil are you gonna do back oh god it's
the sexy portion
[Music]
catch the beat when you're doing a solo
like that oh yeah did I done zit I think
I might have done stit I think I did it
oh that is the coolest game that is so
cool hey man I'm getting better 137 holy
crap man I am already sweaty that is
awesome
that is just plain old awesome I love
that that's a fantastic like way to
expand on like the success and appeal of
beat Sabre and stuff like that and
combine a little superhot in there into
a game that we didn't know we needed
that's amazing
if you have VR and it's available on
your set play this it's so good it's
it's mind-bendingly good it's just it's
so goddamn good I love that I love
everything about that I've got nothing
else to say it's just amazing so thank
you everybody so much for watching you
can play this game for yourself uh put a
link in the description yeah holy crap
that was so much fun I'm gonna play that
again all the time so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and if you haven't checked out a heist
with markiplier why don't you check it
down in the description below it's a
great series worked really hard on it
everybody loves it if you haven't seen
it yet go check it out 31 endings which
one's gonna be yours thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]